Sept secondes !
Tu te rends compte Haristote :
sept secondes !
C’est vraiment rien !
Bon,
on va quand même les économiser.
Sept secondes :
il paraît que c’est la durée
de la PREMIÈRE impression.
Vous rencontrez une nouvelle personne,
et au bout de sept secondes,
vous avez déjà une opinion arrêtée sur
elle.
Mais le plus important,
le plus FRAPPANT aussi,
c’est que cette première impression,
forgée en seulement sept secondes,
va INFLUENCER fortement
votre rapport avec cette personne.
C’est un effet psychologique
qui s’appelle
le « BIAIS de confirmation » :
l’esprit humain cherche toujours à CONFIRMER
ses premières impressions.
On vous sourit ?
Vous allez remarquer EN PRIORITÉ
les marques de sympathie.
On vous manifeste de l’hostilité ?
Vous serez AVEUGLE
à toute manifestation de sympathie,
parce que vous vous focaliserez
sur ce qui CONFIRME
votre première impression.
Pourquoi est-ce que je vous explique ça ?
Hein Haristote,
pourquoi est-ce que je parle
du biais de confirmation ?
Je vous en parle
parce que l’INTRODUCTION de la dissertation
crée un biais de confirmation
chez le correcteur.
Si elle est conforme à ses attentes,
alors il situera,
consciemment ou inconsciemment,
votre copie dans une fourchette de notes HAUTE
;
puis il remarquera en priorité,
dans la suite du devoir,
les éléments qui CONFIRMENT
son a priori positif.
Inversement,
si l’introduction « ne fait pas le job
»,
alors vous créez
un biais de confirmation NÉGATIF,
ce qui veut dire que le correcteur remarquera
TOUS les petits défauts de votre copie
– des détails qu’il aurait négligés
après une BONNE introduction.
En clair,
étant donné le biais de confirmation,
réussir l’introduction est CRUCIAL
pour réussir la dissertation.
Je vais donc vous donner
les trois secrets pour réussir
l’introduction de la dissertation.
Je ne vais pas vous expliquer dans le détail
comment faire une introduction
parce que j’ai un cours gratuit de méthodologie
qui vous explique TOUT de A à Z,
avec des schémas et des exemples.
Vous pouvez vous aussi recevoir
mon cours gratuit
de méthodologie de la dissertation
soit en cliquant sur le lien
qui s’affiche en haut à droite,
soit en utilisant celui qui est
dans la description de cette vidéo.
Inscrivez-vous,
et vous m’en direz des nouvelles.
Après,
le moyen le plus rapide
de réussir l’introduction de dissertation,
c’est de regarder cette vidéo,
parce que je vais vous révéler trois secrets
pour rédiger une introduction qui plaise
au correcteur
— N’IMPORTE QUEL correcteur.
Regardez bien la vidéo jusqu’au bout,
parce que je vais vous donner des techniques
précises
à appliquer DÈS votre prochain devoir,
et surtout ne manquez pas la fin de la vidéo
parce que je vous dévoile des astuces de
style
que je réserve normalement à mes élèves.
Allez,
PREMIER secret
pour réussir l’introduction de la dissertation
!
Ah t’as vu Haristote :
y’a pas de définitions dans son introduction
!
C’est fou ça !
Tout le monde sait
qu’il faut définir les termes du sujet
dans l’introduction, non ?
Bon allez,
je lui mets six,
et on va se balader.
C’est ce qui risque de vous arriver
si vous ne définissez PAS les termes du sujet.
Le PREMIER secret,
c’est donc plus généralement
de respecter TOUTES les conventions méthodologiques
de l’introduction de la dissertation.
Alors,
qu’est-ce que je veux dire par
« conventions » ?
Les conventions,
ce sont les éléments que le correcteur s’attend
à trouver
dans votre introduction.
Je vous rappelle que la dissertation est
un exercice SCOLAIRE,
ce qui veut dire que l’introduction est
réussie
SI ET SEULEMENT SI
elle plaît au correcteur.
Or le correcteur,
c’est un peu le gardien de l’orthodoxie,
c’est-à-dire qu’il considère qu’il
y a une BONNE manière
de rédiger une dissertation,
avec des consignes de base
– et il s’attend à ce qu’elles soient
suivies.
Maintenant,
quelles sont ces conventions ?
Le correcteur s’attend à trouver QUATRE
choses
dans l’introduction de la dissertation.
*1*
Tout d’abord,
une accroche,
ou une « amorce »
– ce sont,
comme vous le savez probablement,
les TOUTES premières phrases de la dissertation,
qui servent deux objectifs :
capter l’attention du lecteur,
et démontrer un intérêt pour le sujet
– de manière un peu artificielle,
c’est vrai.
Alors,
je sais que certains profs disent
qu’on peut se dispenser de ces phrases d’accroche,
et ça peut se défendre
– mais honnêtement,
on ne vous demande pas la Lune non plus,
et puis commencer l’introduction de la dissertation
directement par la définition des termes
du sujet,
c’est-à-dire la partie la plus CHIANTE
à lire,
je ne pense pas que ça mette le correcteur
de bonne humeur.
Donc MON conseil,
c’est de prendre la peine de rédiger une
accroche,
ce qui n’est pas forcément compliqué
avec les BONNES techniques
et un peu d’entraînement.
*2*
Deuxième chose que le correcteur s’attend
à voir
dans l’introduction de la dissertation :
eh bien c’est ce qui était absent
de la dissertation que j’ai montrée à
Haristote,
la DÉFINITION des termes du sujet.
Ça honnêtement,
tous les profs le répètent,
dans toutes les matières,
et ils ont deux-cent pour cent raison !
Ils ont bien raison
parce que c’est impossible de réfléchir
avec rigueur
SANS définir les termes du problème intellectuel.
Le philosophe Thomas Hobbes a montré
que c’est souvent le LAXISME
dans la définition des termes
qui est à l’origine des raisonnements délirants.
Donc si vous ne voulez pas LOUPER le sujet,
DÉFINISSEZ ses termes,
et présentez les définitions dans l’introduction.
*3*
Troisième chose que le correcteur s’attend
à voir
dans l’introduction de la dissertation :
la PROBLÉMATIQUE.
Vous voyez ce que c’est,
la problématique ?
C’est la question UNIQUE
située à la FIN de l’introduction.
Elle sert à exprimer le problème intellectuel
que vous allez RÉSOUDRE
dans la dissertation.
C’est vrai qu’elle peut être difficile
à formuler cette question,
mais le correcteur n’attend pas
de la grande littérature
– il veut juste comprendre le problème
intellectuel
que vous posez.
S’il ne lit AUCUNE question
à la fin de votre introduction,
c’est GRAVE,
parce que le but de la dissertation
c’est PRÉCISÉMENT
de résoudre un problème intellectuel.
Disserter SANS problématique,
c’est un peu comme jouer au foot sans ballon
– personnellement,
je ne vois pas trop l’intérêt.
*4*
Quatrième et dernière chose
que le correcteur s’attend à voir
dans l’introduction de la dissertation :
l’annonce de plan.
Alors,
l’annonce de plan n’est pas exactement
DANS l’introduction,
– parce qu’il faut sauter une ligne
après la problématique –
mais en pratique,
on en parle dans la méthodologie
de l’introduction.
Comme pour l’accroche,
je sais que certains profs demandent
de ne PAS annoncer le plan
– et là aussi ça peut se défendre –
mais c’est inutile de se prendre la tête
pour ça.
Je réponds toujours aux élèves :
dans cent pour cent,
ou dans quatre-vingt-dix-neuf pour cent
des meilleures copies,
on trouve une annonce de plan,
donc terminez l’introduction de vos dissertations
par une annonce de plan.
Voilà,
j’en ai terminé avec les QUATRE conventions
attendues par les correcteurs.
Pour réussir l’introduction de la dissertation,
vous DEVEZ les respecter.
Vous n’avez pas le choix,
parce que le correcteur,
c’est votre ARBITRE
– c’est lui,
et LUI SEUL,
qui décide de vous mettre une bonne note,
ou pas –
donc si vous le contrariez
dès le début de la dissertation,
c’est mal barré.
Vous créez un biais de confirmation NÉGATIF.
Inversement,
en respectant TOUTES les conventions
de l’introduction de la dissertation,
vous montrez au correcteur que vous JOUEZ
le jeu,
et vous vous le mettez dans la poche.
Mais pour ça,
vous pouvez faire ENCORE MIEUX.
Regardez cette introduction.
Est-ce que vous avez envie de la lire ?
Honnêtement,
on a mal à la tête après deux phrases.
Or,
il y a une chose SIMPLE
que l’élève aurait pu faire,
pour faciliter la lecture.
Vous avez pas une idée ?
Eh bien il aurait pu
SUBDIVISER son introduction
en plusieurs paragraphes
– ce qui veut dire,
en pratique,
ajouter un alinéa au début de chaque partie
de l’introduction de sa dissertation.
Le DEUXIÈME secret pour réussir
l’introduction de la dissertation,
c’est donc de la SUBDIVISER en paragraphes.
C’est un moyen FACILE
et IMMÉDIAT
de faciliter la lecture du correcteur.
Et ça,
ça n’est pas négligeable,
parce que la correction est une tâche PÉNIBLE.
Eh oui,
mettez-vous à la place du correcteur :
il doit corriger des textes qui sont d’un
niveau médiocre
par rapport à son niveau à lui,
qui est un expert de la matière
– il ne lit pas pour son plaisir personnel,
et il ne choisit pas ce qu’il lit –
ajoutez à cela le fait que les dissertations
sont TOUTES sur le même sujet ;
et enfin,
il n’en corrige pas seulement quelques-unes,
mais plutôt des dizaines,
voire des centaines
– donc c’est une tâche RÉPÉTITIVE,
avec un gros volume.
Pour ces raisons que je viens d’énumérer,
vous avez fortement intérêt
à FACILITER la lecture du correcteur.
Et la MEILLEURE manière de le faire,
c’est de subdiviser
l’introduction de la dissertation
en différents paragraphes.
Après,
comment faire plus précisément ?
Ce que je vous recommande,
c’est de consacrer
UN PARAGRAPHE ENTIER
à chaque ENJEU de l’introduction
– ça sera beaucoup plus clair
pour le correcteur.
Du coup,
quels sont les ENJEUX de l’introduction
?
Je pense que vous les connaissez,
il y en a quatre :
les deux premiers,
ce sont l’accroche
et la définition des termes du sujet,
dont j’ai déjà parlé ;
ensuite,
il y a la problématisation,
la partie de l’introduction dans laquelle
vous expliquez
le point de départ de votre réflexion,
c’est-à-dire l’idée qui vous a mené
au problème intellectuel
à résoudre dans la dissertation
– donc là,
on est au TROISIÈME paragraphe ;
quatrième et dernier enjeu,
c’est la problématique,
que j’ai également évoquée.
Ça veut dire que la question constitue à
elle seule
un UNIQUE paragraphe,
– ça peut sembler bizarre,
mais ça ne pose aucun problème,
et surtout ça permet au correcteur,
qui est souvent pressé,
d’identifier IMMÉDIATEMENT
votre problématique.
Enfin,
il reste encore l’annonce de plan,
mais elle constitue de toute manière un paragraphe,
puisqu’elle est séparée de l’introduction
par un saut de ligne.
Voici à quoi ressemble la structure idéale
d’une introduction de dissertation :
L’avantage avec cette structure,
c’est que le correcteur sait IMMÉDIATEMENT
OÙ il en est dans sa lecture.
Vous êtes transparent avec lui,
vous lui facilitez la tâche,
et ça,
il vous en sera reconnaissant
quand il décidera de votre note.
Mais si vous voulez qu’il AIME votre introduction,
vous devez appliquer
le troisième et dernier secret.
Regardez bien la vidéo jusqu’au bout,
parce que je vais vous dévoiler des astuces
de style
que je réserve normalement
à mes élèves.
Est-ce que vous lisez les rapports de jury
?
Moi oui
— souvent même.
Ça me permet de savoir EXACTEMENT
ce que les correcteurs valorisent
— ce qu’ils aiment,
et ce qu’ils n’aiment PAS dans une dissertation.
« La qualité de la langue
et de l'expression
constitue une exigence PRIMORDIALE du jury.
»
Ça c’est une phrase
tirée du rapport du jury
de la dissertation de Français
du concours de Polytechnique
de 2018
— mais TOUS les rapports
disent la MÊME chose :
si c’est BIEN écrit,
c’est mieux noté.
Et c’est bien normal,
parce que c’est le but
de l’exercice de la dissertation :
vérifier le niveau d’expression écrite
de l’élève.
Alors là,
vous pouvez me dire :
d’accord,
mais qu’est-ce que ça change
pour l’introduction en particulier ?
Eh bien il faut penser
à la correction pour comprendre :
l’introduction est la partie de la dissertation
que le correcteur lit
avec LE PLUS de soin,
ou disons plutôt
LE MOINS rapidement.
Du coup,
si vous voulez le convaincre
de la qualité de votre expression écrite,
eh bien c’est DANS L’INTRODUCTION
que ça se joue !
En général,
le correcteur regarde le développement
plutôt en diagonale,
en tout cas moins attentivement
– mais l’introduction,
il la lit vraiment,
parce que ça lui permet de se faire rapidement
une idée de votre niveau
et de vous situer dans une fourchette de notes.
Alors maintenant,
COMMENT écrire
pour plaire au correcteur ?
Est-ce qu’il faut faire du Proust,
ou du Platon ?
Évidemment que NON,
pas besoin de viser le prix Nobel de littérature
– bien au contraire,
il vaut mieux éviter.
En fait,
vous devez toujours
chercher la MÊME chose :
FACILITER la lecture du correcteur.
Et pour ce faire,
vous devez écrire CLAIREMENT.
Qu’est-ce que ça veut dire
« écrire clairement » ?
Ça veut dire que le lecteur vous comprend
IMMÉDIATEMENT.
Il n’a pas besoin de faire un effort,
d’essayer de deviner
ce que vous voulez dire,
il n’hésite pas,
– le sens de vos phrases est transparent.
Alors,
maintenant que vous connaissez le principe,
je vais vous donner TROIS astuces
pour écrire plus clairement.
*1*
La première,
c’est de faire attention
à la LONGUEUR des phrases.
Plus une phrase est longue,
moins elle a de chances d’être claire
– vous avez donc intérêt
à rédiger des phrases plus courtes.
Bien sûr,
ça ne veut pas dire
que vous devez enchaîner les slogans.
La règle que vous pouvez suivre,
c’est de mettre un point
dès que vous pensez que c’est possible.
Après,
vous écrirez forcément des phrases
plus ou moins longues,
selon ce que vous voulez dire.
Ce que vous pouvez faire à cet égard,
c’est d’essayer d’alterner les phrases
courtes
et les phrases moins courtes
– c’est un moyen facile de créer du dynamisme,
et donc de capter l’attention du lecteur.
*2*
Deuxième astuce
pour écrire plus clairement :
utilisez un lien logique
dans CHAQUE phrase
pour la lier à la précédente.
En effet
Ainsi
Dès lors
Or
En revanche
Cependant
et caetera
Ça sera peut-être difficile au début,
mais ça va vous forcer
à développer vos idées
avec FLUIDITÉ.
Et puis surtout,
ça va faciliter la lecture du correcteur,
puisqu’il saura immédiatement,
en voyant le lien logique,
le rapport entre la phrase
et la précédente.
Certains disent que ça n’est pas très
subtil.
Certes,
mais le correcteur ne fait PAS
une lecture subtile de la copie
— ce n’est pas comme quand il lit
de la poésie en terrasse d’un café.
Je vous l’ai déjà expliqué :
il corrige de manière expéditive,
il va à l’essentiel –
donc il faut lui montrer GROSSIÈREMENT
les qualités de l’expression écrite.
*3*
Troisième et dernière astuce
pour écrire plus clairement :
ÉVITEZ le jargon.
Le « jargon »,
c’est le vocabulaire TECHNIQUE
propre à la matière
dans laquelle vous dissertez.
C’est par exemple « ontologie »
en philosophie,
« anticipations rationnelles »
en économie,
« habitus »
en sociologie,
et caetera.
Mon conseil concernant l’usage ces mots,
c’est :
si vous n’êtes pas sûr de BIEN connaître
leur sens,
et/ou si vous ne les utilisez pas naturellement
dans la conversation,
alors ne les utilisez PAS en dissertation,
parce que
ce que vous risquez de faire,
c’est de vous dénoncer vous-même,
de RÉVÉLER votre incompétence,
et surtout de COMPLIQUER le propos,
parce que vous ne maîtrisez pas
les nuances du concept.
Utilisez donc EXCLUSIVEMENT
les mots que vous comprenez ;
n’essayez pas de passer pour un expert
pour impressionner le correcteur.
Voilà,
en résumé :
si vous faites attention
à la LONGUEUR des phrases,
si vous insérez un lien logique
dans CHAQUE phrase,
et si vous ÉVITEZ le jargon,
vous rendrez votre expression écrite beaucoup
plus claire,
et donc vous marquerez des points
dans l’esprit du correcteur.
Si EN PLUS
vous respectez les conventions,
et si vous consacrez un paragraphe
à CHAQUE enjeu,
ALORS LÀ
l’introduction de votre dissertation
a de bonnes chances
de plaire au correcteur.
MAIS LÀ j’y pense,
il y a peut-être un QUATRIÈME secret,
en fait.
Le QUATRIÈME secret,
c’est que vous avez besoin
d’une BONNE méthode de dissertation
pour réussir l’introduction.
Bah oui,
parce que la qualité de l’introduction
DÉCOULE de la qualité de la problématisation,
qui DÉCOULE de la qualité de l’analyse
du sujet,
et caetera.
Bref,
tout est lié dans la dissertation,
donc si vous réussissez les premières étapes,
vous avez plus de chances de réussir les
suivantes
— dont la rédaction de l’introduction.
Ce n’est pas vraiment un « secret »,
mais les élèves oublient souvent les CONNEXIONS
entre les différentes opérations intellectuelles
et rédactionnelles
de l’exercice de la dissertation.
Pour acquérir une BONNE méthode de dissertation,
et ainsi réussir TOUTES les étapes de l’exercice,
je vous invite à vous inscrire pour recevoir
mon cours gratuit de méthodologie de la dissertation
soit en cliquant sur le lien
qui s’affiche en haut à droite,
soit en utilisant celui
qui est dans la description de cette vidéo.
Si vous avez des questions sur l’introduction
de la dissertation,
n’hésitez pas à me les poser dans les
commentaires,
et j’y répondrai sans faute.
Je suis Romain,
je suis toujours avec mon fidèle Haristote,
et vous étiez sur 1000 idées de culture
générale.
Rappelez-vous que n’avez pas besoin de vous
prendre la tête
pour réussir l’introduction de la dissertation.